well kirsten this summer nearly a
thousand women with
all types of cancers were surveyed about
emotional and lifestyle recovery
now nearly half of them rated support
for body image
issues and also improved self-esteem as
extremely important to their overall
recovery we're talking about
they ranked it a 10 out of 10 that's how
important it was
so companies like cancer be glammed and
wrapped in love
are here to get them through it the top
five recovery and lifestyle products
women used or wanted were
hair loss solutions things like hair
scarves and hats and wigs
post operative clothing like stylish
mastectomy bras wraps and garments with
easy access to their chemotherapy ports
lisa lori is a breast cancer survivor
and also the co-founder of cancer be
gland
it's traumatic and there's a lot to go
through
many women find that once they're
survivors
they finally get out of that track of
constant
treatment and care and that's kind of
when the whole reality of what they've
been through
and i know i certainly felt this way
sorta
came down on me so more than a decade
ago she gathered a number of these
supportive services to offer them all
under one
umbrella lori also urges women to talk
to their oncology nurse or their doctor
and find those support groups find those
places to get the products they need
because there are a lot of resources out
there now doctors often talk about that
connection between mental health
and physical health so having those
resources can really make all the
difference
in lifting spirits and giving a renewed
sense of beauty to those patients
brian